another thing
that has carried over from your youth
are your tattoos
which i've heard you talk about
but never seen
what's your relationship with your
tattoos and why has no one ever seen
them yeah um
yeah actually it was tim ferriss that
outed me on this one he was like i found
a picture on the internet with you in
full sleeves um
yeah you know i believe that you know
tattoos are i mean this has come as no
surprise or a
literal expression of what we feel on
the inside and you know i and i'm not
recommending this kids don't do this i
started getting tattooed really young
how again about 14 i got my first tattoo
no we did them ourselves
within your first one please don't no
please no one do this india inc and a
needle and um we used to do these is
really bad they're called knick-knack
tattoos or we kind of would do this at
home don't do it it's really bad you get
bad infections they're ugly they they
blur they bleed that's not good um yeah
i started getting tattooed i when i was
a kid and growing up skateboarding in
the punk rock scene there were these
guys in
the town where i lived they called
themselves the yahtzee guys i don't know
why i don't know what that was about but
they all had full sleeves and they were
super nice guys and they were all into
skateboarding and
you know and vehicles and i just looked
up to these guys i thought oh like
someday i want full sleeves i
yeah i've i've got full sleeves i'm
basically like neck to neck to wrist
sort of chest piece as well yeah but
yeah
uh backs covered yeah nothing on my legs
nothing on my stomach ribs yeah the tops
of my tops of my shoulders and um i got
a big picture of costello my dog back
there i've got a picture of his paw back
there i've got a picture of another dog
used to have um there's still some space
for a few things there's some things
very personal to me um is that the
reason that you prefer not to show them
yeah you know i think that there are a
couple reasons i'll just be clear as to
why first of all um when i show up to
podcast it's the same way i show up to
lecture in the um classroom auditorium
and i
swear in my life this is my mindset and
this is my mantra when i do it i'm there
to teach it's not about me it's about
the student it's about the people
learning
i don't want it ever to be about me i
don't want the focus to be on me i mean
obviously i'm the voice and the person
talking but i really want people to
internalize the information and i do
think that the tattoos because they have
nothing to do with the information are a
distraction they're just a distraction i
i don't know it would sort of like be
wearing like a bright yellow shirt or
something it's not my style i prefer to
kind of make myself disappear as much as
i can
and let the information come forward
that's you know even when i gave
scientific lectures which i still do of
course for my my professor job
i generally liked the room to be pretty
dark and i wanted the light to be on the
data on the slides i was happy to do the
voice but i want people thinking about
the data
so podcasting is a little different you
come through as a voice not or on
youtube a voice in an image but
i really prefer that it not be about me
now there's a human element too and i
think things have changed a lot when i
was growing up tattoos were not accepted
there are many work environments where
if you have for instance
where
people prefer that their surgeon or
their doctor not have tattoos some
people might prefer their surgeon or
doctor have tattoos when i was growing
up if you had a uh i never had one but
if someone had a nose ring they had to
cover it up with a band-aid or take it
out if they worked at the coffee shop
remember that you probably don't you're
probably young enough no
or eyebrow ring trends have changed
right things have changed and i'm kind
of old school because i'm kind of old
now 46. um and the etiquette for me has
always been
to you know and this is lex does this
too is i i personally
find that if i can just show up as
formal and consistent as possible that
people at least know that i'm taking
them seriously so i don't really do it
for me i pretty much do it for the
audience um
and also none of the tattoos are like
that interesting it's my dog i've i
really like raptors i've got a bunch of
birds i've got i mean i have all sorts
of different things raptors like the
dinosaur no raptors like um
red tail hawks and blue you know i like
birds and i had either dinosaurs or
trucks yeah like yo you really need to
love ford raptors no no no ford raptor i
drive a toyota forerunner and i love it
i got one truck and i love that thing um
although with gas right now i mean it's
you kind of got to wonder about having a
gas driven vehicle like a forerunner in
any case yeah the tattoo thing i would
say for for younger people coming up
just be aware that you can't control
other people's perceptions either and so
you know i always made it a point that i
didn't want things on my knuckles i
didn't want them on my hands i didn't
want them on my neck i didn't want them
on my face do i judge people when they
have them no but do i want them for me
no i also think that this is very
neurosciency
as neuroscience is that we have
dedicated brain areas called fusiform
gyrus face area that's dedicated to the
processing of faces even if i just put
two dots and a line in between them on a
piece of paper you see that as a face
when one puts a tattoo on their throat
or on their face it actually changes the
way that the face is perceived right i
mean it almost looks like another mouth
there right it's a very different look
it's it can be a little bit jarring i'm
not saying one shouldn't have it but it
can be a little bit jarring it's it
changes the look of the person forever
it's not just that it's above the
neckline it's that it kind of competes
with the processing of their face in its
normal way and so for me whenever i see
somebody with a throat tattoo or a face
tattoo sort of like it's hard to orient
around that and i think there's some
biology to uh to that relates to that
but like when it comes down to it i mean
people need to be individuals and live
their life the way they want to live
their life
i've also never been that much of an
iconoclast i'm not
you know i'm i
grew up in the punk rock thing um
you know i hate in group out group stuff
i always had friends from a lot of
different you know friends that are
jocks and hippies and punk rockers and
you know straight and gay and like i
don't care as long as people are living
in their best life and they're not
harming anybody like i'm like great go
for it i i'm very laid back in that way
of course if people are harming other
people
then i believe that
liberty and independent freedom i mean
liberty is you know one of the highest
things that you know for me so
but i don't tend to i don't consider
myself a very judgmental person but
you can't always control the perceptions
of others so i just think people should
be thoughtful about what they want to
accomplish in life in terms of a life
mission and just ask whether or not some
of the permanent cosmetic changes they
might make might might align with
compete with or be neutral for those
life missions my life mission is very
simple i want to teach people the beauty
and the utility of biology i'm going to
do that today i'm going to do that until
i take my last breath in one form or
another because that's what excites me
and that's like what keeps the dopamine
cranking what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace